[Music]
you're watching summer game fest i'm
tomorrow saying and i am excited to be
joined by fleur mati uh executive
producer on gotham nights as well as
jeff eleanor um game director on gotham
knights um and we are going to be
talking about gotham nice how are you
folks doing
awesome good thanks
are you i'm i'm doing great you know i'm
better now that i've seen nightwing um
i've seen nightwing's uh cheeks let's
call them because everyone knows those
are the best feature the best part of uh
at nightwing um
yeah very very popular subject um
we saw a bit of the game during uh the
keeley's
the other day and uh it's given us one
of the most uh memorable moments from
the show so far which is jeff keeley
shouting uh batman is dead with an
enthusiasm that uh i'm sure would upset
quite a few members of the family how
was it like to see that because when it
happened where he was like batman is
dead i was like wow i don't know you
should be dancing on his grave jeff
batman is dead
how did you how did you like take that
moment
we've come to terms with our grief over
the development cycle
and also i mean it's it's great to see
other people shouting it on the rooftops
because i mean people still don't
believe us but really he's dead i i mean
this is a i'll never believe you until i
see the credits on on the game like if i
think people still think you're gonna
play through level three and surprise
you're batman yeah i'm i'm i'm waiting
for the moment where like uh i don't
know nightwing like removes the mask and
it's been in it's been bruce the entire
time he's like a mission impossible in
it um but yeah you guys introduced or
showed off more of nightwing um during
during the actual gameplay video um
nightwing obviously a character that has
a long and storied history in dc and
batman particularly um what is this
version of nightwing that uh we're gonna
be playing where he is he at in his life
and what are kind of the main concerns
for him in in in this version of the
game
well so
where he is in his life is is a bit it's
a complicated moment for him because uh
he's just back he's just back in gotham
because bruce is dead and and actually
he
had a big fight with him right before a
living
for blood heaven so he comes back and
he's breathing
and
he's also like
trying to find his place but at the same
time you know that when he's he's the
goofy
like i make jokes and all that to not
have to
deal with any of that
um
and and he needs to at the very same
time process his own grief
but also like work with the rest of uh
the batman family um so it's a bit
complicated for him
in terms of
actual gameplay we've we've obviously
had some experience playing as nightwing
and playing alongside nightwing before
um can you tell us a little bit about
how what this version of nightwing is
like is it going to be familiar to the
previous iterations that we've seen in
in the arkhamverse which i know is it's
kind of like
separate and that kind of stuff but um
obviously there is a touchdown there how
does he play and what does he bring to
the dynamic in gotham nights
i would say compared to other superhero
uh
games with similar types of combat uh
nightwing is maybe one of the more
familiar is because of his long reach
uh he's his specialty is switching
between targets he's a very aerial uh
hero out of the ones we have and a lot
of his moves focus on that get back up
into the air and deal
lots of damage so he has aspects of
familiarity there
but also all of the moves that we've
brought to the fight for him are
pretty unique to the game and also our
uh quickfire
patterns with the wrist arts
i don't think players have had that much
flexibility in how they targeted and
with what before so it will be
familiarish to onboard but also quite
new
is it tricky to have characters
that have such diverse styles operating
in the same kind of space because you
have a character like nightwing and
obviously he's got a background as a
gymnast and a performer and you
obviously want to represent that in his
fighting style but then you have i don't
know like red hood who's not that like
how do you kind of create is it is it
difficult to create a kind of like
cohesion between them um how do you
approach that when you know that one
player is probably going to be flying
all over the place and the other one's
probably just going to be like moving
around gunning people down and that kind
of stuff what we found is that if people
play together uh
cohesion happens in the same way as if
you were two people trying to get into
an elevator like you you both have very
powerful verbs at your disposal
regarding
you know who regardless of who you're
playing
so whether you're playing uh
red hood or back girl your verbs are
very different uh familiar but different
than what nightwing does
and as a result you kind of develop a
different rhythm when you play with
somebody who's using that hero because
of the way they move around the arena
and also how you choose targets and how
you choose to cooperate with them as
well
interesting um in terms of like narrow
airflow um obviously you have one of the
big things that has exciting people is
the court or vowels and
and that element uh being included in
knights and
um
obviously uh dick was at one point uh
being uh kind of
trained or he was they had their eyes on
him to be one of the talent um
does that factor into the the nightwing
is that history there for the nightwing
or uh you know he was he was he has a
deep connection with the court of hours
before i guess william cobb became
battalion and how much does that play
into your version of the story
so
you know
as we've always said like our story is
really yes it is taking inspiration from
the variety of the comics but it's
really
original so um
it's
you it you won't you will find some
threads of other things but it's not
directly linked to any of it just like
when we're talking about how bad girl
got injured uh it's not exactly in the
same way as what we've known before
so
um you shouldn't be expecting to find
exact
uh
follow-ups of previous uh stories in the
in the bad members
yeah i guess like a lot of those
background things of canon and we've
selected elements of each to build the
the web for our story and and for the
background for each one of our heroes
and how it impacts different elements
[Music]
how do you actually select what you want
to keep and
and what you want to kind of like not
keep because obviously it's it must be
tricky knowing that if we have this
element of it people
might be attached to this thread and
they might not be able to
create that distance it becomes harder
to kind of tell yourself and um that
it's a different unique story when you
keep seeing elements of the original
appear in
all the or another story appear in your
thing so how do you strike that balance
right it's like we're inspired by we're
not that thing
i think we have the same creative
challenge as a lot of the people who
work with this amazing deep dcip around
gotham city
and
uh
we
it sounds challenging it was really fun
for us uh
we kind of focused on what were the
touchstones we wanted for each hero to
make them really different from each
other
both for gameplay inspiration reasons
and also for like how they interact with
each other in the story and what their
personal growth moments are going to be
throughout the story
and i think we've done a fun job of it
so you'll you'll see elements that spark
familiarity and as you play you'll also
see some moments that
maybe players have never experienced
before even if they're really hardcore
dc fans and i think it all boils down to
at some point for the narrative team
it was what is coherent
uh
when you're looking at each of the floor
but also their story together plus the
overarching story of the game um and and
i think
an actual awesome job yeah
yeah i'd love to dig a bit deeper on
that kind of the story element of it can
you talk a bit about how that unfolds
you obviously have a main story that
you're telling but then each individual
character presumably has their own arc
that they go on um
do they have like individual arcs for
themselves and then also like
a shared arc with other characters who
depending on who you pair them with how
do you kind of take these narrative
threads and weave them together and and
what is the objective with that it must
be like super complicated
the main
it's really a matrix of possibility for
the players we
the complexity ends up happening
when players put it all together
themselves
creatively it wasn't that complex for us
because we wanted the
uh
you choose which hero you go through the
story with you can switch if you decide
you want to play with somebody else
but generally speaking you're
experiencing it through the
storyline of whoever you're playing in
the game
and there are moments that are unique to
your hero
you know sort of like impacting
uh the character's
emotional journey i would say through
the game
but when you go on to uh a main story
beat there there there are slight
differences in the storytelling of like
who says what but everybody goes on the
same adventure and everybody overcomes
the same challenges in the game and
that's where it really kind of ties
everything back to
a single path which allows us to provide
a really solid
experience for the story that we wanted
to tell and you might have seen me
laughing when jeff was saying uh
creatively it wasn't a challenge i was
laughing just because i was thinking
about wilson
our cinematic director would have me in
a headlock exactly
because of course like
as deaf was saying although all all of
them are going on the same adventure
whether you are especially when you're
interacting with certain known
characters of the the world uh depending
on who you're playing they have
completely well pretty different
conversations so for our cinematics team
it meant creating literally four
versions of each other's synthetic so
that was a really good job and the
heroes are not the same size sorry
i shouldn't have said it
uh i'm interested in how do you how does
that mean what does that mean for like
narrative beats because in my mind i'm
like presumably there's going to be a
point where i don't know red hood is not
getting on with
uh
grayson and they don't want to be near
each other how does the game deal with
two players controlling them being like
no i want to play as red hood and i'm
going to play as nightwing because
they're who are main but is there ever a
moment where it's like
how do you approach an idea where it's
like we need these two to not be near
each other but players are going to want
to play them and put them together so
how do you approach something like that
so we try we try to create not
situations like that first of all
uh
but but yes they do have different kinds
of relationships depending on who is uh
with whom but it's never coming to a
point where we would have to tell the
player no you can't play co-op with with
red hood today because no you're mad at
him yeah
we always want to allow our players to
act out and to play the game the way
they want to play that that's that's
always been a failure of the project for
us
so even though there are beats in the
story where there's some angry tension
between
individuals in the story
uh
when you take the controls and you play
with a friend you can either act out
that angry tension or not all right
obviously like for me like one of the
most i think like for a lot of fans of
superhero teams it's always like one of
the most interesting moments is when
there's that that narrative beat where
it's like oh no are they gonna break up
so i guess you you're not able to have
that kind of
tension that kind of tension in this but
you are coming at it uh bringing
different kinds of tension in that can
you talk a little bit about how you do
explore the idea of tension when you
have these individual characters that
are so different but also need to be
together always
[Music]
i don't want to give away too much much
of the story i'll just say in a response
to the question that uh our characters
are always in gotham
and
the
heroes don't always agree
with their perspective on different
characters in gotham that they have to
interact with some people will think
that they should trust so-and-so and
some people are like i'm not really into
trusting so on so
it impacts the storytelling in that way
final question i have to ask
what is the deal with red hood's double
jump which in a previous trailer was
explained
quite like very quickly as some sort of
soul thing like
seeing red hood have supernatural
abilities like a double jump um what is
the deal with that how did you
reconcile that narratively
uh
it is canada that red hood in some story
lines is a very mystic
figure and one of the ways that we were
excited about making him different
from
all of the other heroes in our game is
that he's
resurrected
he was dead
so he has a connection
uh to certain
spiritual forces in our game universe
that
the other heroes don't have and so he
expresses that through his abilities not
just in his traversal but it's on his
other abilities as well
gotcha awesome well fleur jeff thank you
so much for your time um i'm excited to
check out more of gotham nights and for
people watching make sure to keep it on
game support for further uh jeff kd
coverage of a key three we'll see you
soon bye
thank you bye
[Music]
you